good to be here with you and good to be
here without you actually
it'd be awkward if you were all here at
this moment because it'd be too much
this is a small space is minimal
you know you get minimal space and you
just you can't do much with it
to a spider this would be a big room but
to a man this is
uh this is nothing to really write home
about
today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind magic mind
oh damn i dropped it man ta-da
magic mind it um
it is the anti-procrastination sipper
if you want to really create flow state
and get yourself out of procrastination
get that magic mine it's the organic
alternative to five hour energy
magic mine dot co use promo code
theo for 10 off
oh man what's going on a lot a lot the
diamond one baby
you know that boy the diamond one
what else i went hunting i went hunting
for something
um and outdoors hunting
you know not just looking for something
like a remote control i'm talking i did
it i went out there
and i'll tell you about it so i uh
a friend of mine out here an adult he
knows a man
who does falconry you know deviant birds
and i'm not going to say that these
birds are caught up with the dark arts
but us
i mean they are each one of them had
probably half a can of voldemort in them
and that's really the truth and um
so the man does falconry
and um you know bobby kennedy jr had
talked about it when he was a guest on
here about
being around falcons and and you know
kind of doing homing pigeons that sort
of thing when he was growing up
but basically what happened was we went
and met up with this man behind a church
or in front of a church actually first
first we met in front of a church
we pulled up he had a maroon van with
two decent
uh birds in it big
you know big i'm talking about these
things where these things were from the
damn
they were from the middle of the bible
these things they was really
i mean these were you know some of the
get those game of thrones these these
birds
bro if these birds [ __ ] it would drown a
baby you know what i'm saying it was a
they had these birds were they were real
birds
you know like you won't see if you see
one of these birds with a canary
it's only because they trying to [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like these
birds was more about
they were more prehistoric prehistorical
you know like if you went back in time
and and you saw a bird it might be one
of these that's what i'm telling you
so we get out there and the man has two
falcons in the back of a red van
and i didn't believe him you know
because i grew up in kind of a you know
kind of a troubled area and
a lot of times a guy says hey i got two
falcons in the back of a van
somebody's breaking their dick out to be
honest
and uh but this guy you know he it was
they were real honest
and um and they had them you know and
everybody was clothed and they had the
birds
and so we go back behind the church and
he has a friend there another man
and now we're with two men adult men
and they both had on um
what is it called when you're hopeful
the
it's like a basketball rim but it's for
your hand it's like a
um jesus not a championship
uh they both had on wedding rings
and so next thing you know we get in the
woods they have the birds they have a
little dog too
and the dog and they're called uh
tumble creek falconry
i want to get the name right hold on i
think that was it tumble
creek falconry and they do falconing
and uh and so anyway we get out there so
they give us a big stick
because they want you to have a big
stick if you're out there
this thing called what is it called here
uh
turnbull creek falconry and they're
legitimate
and so you get out there and they give
you a big stick like a big like a bottom
of an
axe like an axe like if you're
like if you're an axe person but you
quit axing
you know but you still want to have the
stick but you don't want to have the
blade
and they it's about four feet long and
you go you go along you beat the trees
right you beat the trees
and um and the birds first of all here
let me let me back pedal
hold on
the birds um
[Music]
the birds uh the birds they get them out
the cage they got helmets on they got
little
like uh hide and go seek little outfits
you know almost like if your grandmother
wanted if your grandmother
wanted to make you a hide-and-go-seek
outfit for when you counted that it's
like a little
um it covers your eyes you know what
horses wear
if you've ever been to a fancy city and
they got a couple horses down there
and they usually have an alcoholic
that's running them and they'll you know
for a few dollars they'll pull you and
your lady through the city
and you can ask her if she wants to
marry you or not or whatever you don't
have to ask her
a lot of times by the end of the horse
ride you're like damn i don't even want
to marry this woman
and say you just keep the ring in your
pocket and you go home
but um but anyway it's like the blinders
like the blinders so they have that on
the birds tudor birds they come out they
both got
uh little blinders on full blinders they
can't see anything
like if you asked them how many fingers
you were holding up they wouldn't squawk
so they got the two birds and um
and dude it feels like old school
it feels like you would be the it feels
like if you showed up with these things
you would get the most
[ __ ] at a renaissance fair and i'm
sorry for saying [ __ ] as well
so i want to say that also but um you
would be
oh you would have all the big titty
at a wren fair if you showed up with
these straight up just falcons baby
these heat seekers
i'm talking about the lords freaking
southwest airlines baby
big birds so anyway they come out with
the little head caps on and
they're moving but it looks like they're
sleeping but basically um
so then you start walking in the woods
you take off their head caps
and uh and they fly up into the trees
so now you have two birds up in the air
in the trees and sometimes they'll swoop
off and do us just a loopty loop and
come back to a branch
and so the rest of us men grown men
we wander and you get in different lines
and you wander through the woods
and everybody has like a piece of an axe
a stick an axe bottom an axe leg
i don't know what it's called axe leg
and you hit the trees
with it and you hit the underbrush
and you hit the tree
and you're hoping you round up a
squirrel
or rounds up a little rabbit you know
one of mr mcgregor's little buddies
little cotton tail
and you keep going and the birds they'll
as you walk the birds
they will kind of jump from they'll hop
or kind of coast from one tree to the
next
so you guys are moving in like this like
this unique pack where they're upstairs
and you're downstairs but everybody's in
the same kind of move
moving hunt house it's like this you're
just it's not a real house but you're
just
you know you're kind of in a pack
and then suddenly something will happen
like you'll hit a tree and it'll make a
and a little squirrel will have been
being real secretive
and he'll move his neck
and that that's all it takes for these
uh big birds is one just
just one jostle of a neck muscle and
they
and next thing you know they're on the
tree and they start to
they start to like uh corner the the
squirrel
so we get the squirrel he move and they
corner the squirrel so one of the
birds gets ahead of it one of them blows
it and then they jump from branch to
branch
and then next thing you know one of them
goes in for the attack
and uh and that was it man we you know
we did
they did uh and that's nature
you know people want to say this and
that that's nature baby
okay and it's all you know god laid out
those mar
those marbles you know he laid that's it
we're not you can say this and that but
that's
that's somebody else's plan don't talk
to me about it go pray about it if you
have an issue with it
because that's just that's what those
birds do
so anyway the birds were you know they
get a squirrel and then
oh and the birds will hold the squirrel
down it was wild so they
they caught one squirrel and then they
caught a
there's a little dog as well a little
white and black dog
maybe mexican i don't know i didn't get
a good look in his eyes but he was mixed
he was real real mixed man he uh
he had that jack russell in him baby
that eddie bravo you know what i'm
saying
and he was real pertinent he was real
particular he would go over he was only
hunting
and if you try to pet him or scratch his
belly he'd [ __ ] kick you bro this dog
it wasn't this wasn't no you know he was
on the job that's like a fedex man you
try to run up and tickle him or
something or
you know or hide one of his boxes he
might [ __ ] you up
and that's like this guy this this dog
was
so we went through
and what else did they catch they caught
a rabbit
and a possum
and it was just magical man at the
beginning of the day i'm like scared of
the birds and by the end of the day
i'm like i'm just i'm like i feel like
the birds are like working for me and
i'm in
i mean i feel like i'm on the damn fifth
page of the bible baby i'm keyed up you
know what i'm saying we're hunting and
they're
picking up stuff i'm sending one of the
birds to go get me some uh
twizzlers and mike and ikes like these
bra it's just really
you start to become like uh conning the
barbarian
so it was exceptional man
man it was really really exceptional and
we did some videography of it
and we may put something up at some
point
you know i thought about trying to do
something where i learned new stuff like
just how to do new things or have new
experiences
um because i've been looking for things
in the woods when i was young
but i'd never been actually really
hunting
you know except to hunt oh actually
that's not true i've been i've been out
to hunt
pigs and i've been out to hunt uh boar
like boars but i've been out
been out to hunt um
ducks one time but you know i like that
hand-to-hand combat and it feels more
like that with the uh
with the with the birds with the hawks
there might have been hawks i think they
were
they might have been hawks but um not
atlanta i think they were from well they
must been from here
so yeah local hawks but uh
whatever they were man it was
fascinating it was fascinating and
and yeah we got a real experience and it
was like about a three
four hour high uh hunt and it just
i don't know it just made me feel so
involved with nature
you know it made me feel right there i
just felt
i just felt like a root
that's what i felt like and i'm used to
feeling like a branch
and it was pretty powerful um
so yeah i can't believe i did it and i'm
so grateful that i got to do it my
friend bizzle took me out there and he's
a white guy
even though he has the name of a
nine-year-old black kid he really is a
white man
and he took me out and um
we had this fella named mancell went
with us and did some
videography and uh the fellas that took
us were just great man that's
turnbull creek falconry
and we'll put a link maybe go get an
experience with those guys but it was
worth it was worth uh
it was worth the time it was worth the
time
what else is going on um oh
so on the drive there right i'm driving
out to the
falconry and
i passed by this car like a little red
kind of
um it was like a mustang
maybe or a
it was a uh and this dude was sitting
right by like right by the window
uh and he was driving but also kind of
leaning like towards the window
and he had like he was kind of leaning
up close by the wheel but also by the
window kind of
and he had a track suit on you could see
the edge of the track suit adidas style
and uh and he had like the stripes down
the middle of his car going over the
back you know that [ __ ]
where like it's gonna make you go faster
but it doesn't it just means you
maybe finished high school that kind of
uh
and i thought oh this dude is a drug
dealer
this guy is a heist this guy is a high
school drug dealer
and then it made me think well why do i
think that
and then i realized that every high
school drug dealer
looks the same none of them
there is no no crime person
is worse at disguising themselves
than a high school drug dealer
first of all they all have like a name
like spoony
juicy tate uh little danny bruh
ledan you know uh
uh boof um poop pook
you know they all got the same type of
name they all wear
like kind of that tracksuit slicked hair
with maybe that caesar cut
chain and they all drive like a fancy
car
like they all and there's no you're like
oh that's
the drug dealer like why doesn't the
high school drug dealer
try and look not like a drug dealer
how hard would it be for you to get a
freaking sombrero dog
get a little bro uh tag that says uh
manager you know or even manger misspell
it who gives a [ __ ]
get a freaking name tag get a job at
books of millions man
damn bro you know every drug dealer
unfortunately looks at that oh and they
would some if they didn't wear the um
the uh tracksuit they wear the white tee
the white tee maybe timbalands or maybe
uh you know uh fatty sneakers
and speakers and they all work at a uh
like an auto sound place
all of them that's where they either
work or hang out at
and they just sell drugs to get more and
more speakers put into their car
and then here's what happens sadly the
speakers are so loud when the cops
finally
try to pull them over they can't even
hear the cop sirens
so then they get resisting a rest
because they couldn't eat because the
whole system leads them to not be able
to hear
then they end up as a hard of hearing 30
year old
trying to get a ged but they never
change the style baby
they still drive the mustang they still
have the stripes down the back
dude the drug dealers in high school
sometimes they would even have the word
drugs
spray painted or uh airbrushed
on the back of the car dude if you're
gonna sell drugs
don't write drugs on a car dog
get a overalls get a um
uh that do some disguise yourself
you know get a glasses man get a uh
um axe get an axe man
a shoulder chopper man get an axe
you know you just have to do things to
not look like a drug dealer
but unfortunately every high school
drug dealer looks
only like a drug dealer
praise god baby um today's episode
is brought to you by better help now
look you know
i'm i'm someone who struggled with
mental health
you know and uh self-worth issues and
you know doubting myself um
i think about my feelings a lot and i
feel about my
about my thinking so once i get stuck in
that ping pong space right there it's
really tough for me to operate
and sometimes i need help somebody needs
somebody to help me unlock the doors hey
man what are you doing you in a paddle
ball
court here by yourself i say all right
i'll step out
because otherwise i don't know i'll stay
in there and just
think about my feelings and feel about
my thinkings baby
is there something interfering with your
happiness or that is preventing you from
achieving your goals
well better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist that's what they
do
you know that's what they do better help
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's under two days man
and hell sometimes it can be even
quicker i remember i pulled over on the
side of the road
i'd already created an account and i
pulled over on the side of the road one
day and i needed some help and i got it
immediately better help want you to
start living a happier life today
this is therapy if you need therapy they
can get it for you
you can facetime you can phone time you
can text
visit their website read their
testimonials that are posted daily
betterhelp.com
reviews betterhelp.com theo
and join the over million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
and that is beautiful
that is beautiful shout out to my friend
megan who's almost a
counselor this podcast is sponsored by
better help
and tpw listeners get 10
off uh their first month
at betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
you know i i do a lot of gaming on my
phone
you know recently i've been doing um
what have i been doing
uh what is it called uh
wishing well not wishing well bitcoin
i've been doing bitcoining
but also i've been doing chess you know
i like to play games on my phone
well you know all that time you spent
playing your favorite mobile games on
your phone
you could have been winning money in
prizes that's right
now they're merging making money and
playing games
at skills s-k-i-l-l
dot com turn mobile gaming into cash
baby boy
turn it into cash baby
skills.com literally has the greatest
games on the planet
and you'll probably bump into me there
that's right
i'm getting on i want to play games and
make the money at the same time while
i'm out here milling around
doing nothing i'm playing asteroid belt
or something some game and i
and i'm broke after and hell i was broke
before
change it up skills makes it super easy
to get started and have games for
everyone
classics like solitaire cube and 21
blitz
and fun new games like blackout bingo
hubba hubba it's fair because you're
matched against players at your skill
level
new users use my promo code t-h-e-o
because i got you double the cash to
start playing with double the cash
that's promo code t-h-e-o for double the
cash to get started go to skills.com
t-h-e-o that's s-k-i-l-l-z
with az.com theo make money
while you play your games you on your
lunch break make some money
must be 18 or older terms and conditions
apply not available in all states
see website for details all right
as we come back man i want to make a a a
message out to
uh boots on the ground luke and he's a
fellow over there in baton rouge
louisiana
and he's a white guy maybe ginger semi
ginge
and he uh going in for brain operation
something's wrong with his brain
he said they said he needs more room in
his brain or whatever and
[ __ ] i don't know sound like i wouldn't
even get it done but he's getting it
done
so just want to let you know we love you
luke and um
you know uh you know we hope you survive
and if
and if you survive man um send us in
some pictures or something you know
and do you know show us a before and
after you know show us that new two
three bedroom brain you're gonna have
and if you don't survive but i just want
to let you i hate to say it but
you know let's get it out there and if
you don't survive i just want to let you
know that um
we'll keep you alive here on the podcast
somehow
so uh my thoughts are with you this week
and that's boots on the ground luke over
there and boots on the ground luke is um
he was in a i think he was hit by a
tractor something a couple years back
but
he uh what was
what hold on uh he
he he he gave the best man he was the
one that hit us up a month back about
the best man speech
for his brother and you guys gave him
some recommendations so
wishing him uh the best of luck what
else is going on
oh i saw the uh well look let's get into
it man i saw the
diamond fight baby
and i want to thank everybody for all
the dm's and messages i got
i can't even imagine what dustin got
just
being a friend of dustin's i got um
i got man i must have got 4 000
messages congratulating me
um on that man's victory and he's a
victory man if you saw the
if you saw the fight
you know he came out with a game plan
which it just it showed a lot of
evolution of him as a fighter
i thought this is you know there's two
ways that i look at dustin i look at him
as a
as a friend and somebody that i care
about and then i look at him as a
fighter
you know so um you know on the fighting
side
i think a lot of people expected him to
just come out and be
you know captain punchy out there you
know [ __ ] benedict fists out there
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] larry
knuckles out there just bucking the
trend baby you know
and just hoping for the best um
[Music]
but he came out revamped
i mean he would be a vampire but with
the sharp teeth on the bottom you feel
me he came
out revamped
and he had a plan
and he executed it man and there was
something about him winning
and i felt this in a lot of people that
were what they were cheering him on that
you just felt hopeful
about stuff in your own life or things
in the world you know you felt like
you know the sun was gonna come up
tomorrow you just felt like that a
little
um and i love what his wife said at the
at the end of the fight y'all aren't
gonna
don't doubt my husband again something
like that i just
you know i just
you know they just have never paid him
fair they've never paid him fare
and for him to be there in that hotel
for two weeks
and he's looking out and connor's out
there on that yacht on that bars kind of
owns a damn
barge you know connor's out there just
and i mean i don't know if he could see
it from his hotel window or not but if
that doesn't create some determination
in you um
but i didn't doubt him man i was
definitely scared
for him because connor's a lethal man
he's got that freaking shoulder snake
baby that that freaking arm dog
and his arm is a lot longer than it
looks jesus
you know his arm you could row a boat
with his arm you know he got a long arm
and
um yeah it was just amazing man i i it
was just
it just you know i was excited for
dustin as a fight i was excited for
dustin as a
person as well and about his future and
um yeah it was just man i was just
elated
i was literally swinging from the
rafters
of a bar that we went to to watch it at
like they had some steel beams and i'm
in there just swinging back and forth
like a chump
actually hurt my neck swinging on it
so i've had neck pain and now i just
you know i just have more
um but i just i mean i thought it was a
good fight even it was a quick fight but
i thought it was a good fight
i mean conor was still landing some
blows kev uh
you know dustin was hitting him with
those kicks
i mean it was just a lot going on
man it was but i was just i was i was
just excited i was excited
i was excited man because i picked the
wrong guy a lot of times in fights and
you know
betting on the colts or different [ __ ]
like that to go to the horse races you
lose
you know you lose on you know you better
you know 60 dollars on freaking
you know donny's enemy to come in third
or whatever
or you know whatever it is star burst
enema all
horses have the weirdest names but
finally to get you know just to get it
right
and i want a thousand dollars from your
boy brandon shopvac
and here was the funniest thing was i
got a text from dustin
after the fight and it said
tell brennan he owes you that tell
brennan
he owes you that money that's what he
said man
ah i just can't imagine i think also
there was a level of just feeling proud
of uh for dustin you know and feeling
proud for him and
um yeah i think
there was something about
it was like man i can't imagine how
awesome he must feel right now you know
just how
proud of himself he must feel and just
how
just deserve it you know you finally i
mean damn his experience with the ufc
seemed like he's the one
he goes up to the atm and he's got to
put in money
and finally it comes out and
you know i i think you know i think he's
transcended the sport and
you know i've told him that and um
and i'm i'm excited to see his future
i'm excited to see what he does
inside of the ring and then outside of
the ring um
i think on the fighting side it's
interesting how do you figure out who he
fights next
because
you know if you go for the connor
trilogy that's right there but he just
beat him and it's been five years since
the last one like
you know i agree with dustin that
michael chandler who i love michael
chandler's
uh and i hope to have him back in here
soon and
um but he he should have to fight more
guys
i mean i understand dustin's point of
view you know
uh man i felt bad for dan hooker i
really liked dan hooker he seemed like a
really cool
guy um
i also thought the whole way the fight
came together was amazing you know
um conor mcgregor is irish man he's an
irish man i love ireland
you know shout out dublin you feel me
and shout out scotland as well man
you know and scotland is just drunk
ireland
let's be honest huh and um
and i you know what i thought that i
mean you know the whole thing kind of
started if i and i and i may be wrong
but it started as a charitable thing
conor and dustin were going to fight for
charity to raise money for their
charities
and then ufc saw that and got involved
you know um
and and so the whole thing started from
a place of charity
i thought that conor was was you know
he's a businessman now
i mean he's got to wake up the next day
and do business he's got
you know he there's a difference when
you go from being
an athlete to the owner of the gym
you're doing two different things it's
two different brains
and i'm not saying that conor's not
still one of the greatest fighters of
all time
i believe it is i mean i just watched
all of his fights in the past month um
i remember after i watched all those
fights literally i texted us and i said
hey man where's
how's your how's your head man are you
how you feeling you know
i was [ __ ] scared dude i hurt my neck
i heard my neck watching the fight
that's how excited i was um
but no i thought that kind of was a
class act and i thought that dustin
you know i'm just obviously glad that he
won and
there's just no you know he can't
there's you can't deny him anymore
and i felt his angst after the fight you
could feel his angst you know he's angst
it out and yeah he just said being there
for two weeks and
you know at a certain point if if uh
dana
whatever the man's name is dana wallace
or whatever i don't know what his name
is but dana
uh if big dan had a white money man if
he doesn't
if you don't treat your employees
well enough at some point then they
they're going to lose the desire to work
with you
and i i'm just look i don't know also i
don't know anything
she may be listening to this saying man
theo doesn't know anything
and you'll be and you you would be right
but i i i just
you know you gotta you gotta pay your
employees
you gotta pay them you gotta want them
to ride while you ride
and i think people could say well you
know connor's the one that sells the
tickets and this and that and
some of that's fair very fair
you know what connor's done for that
sport is amazing and and i'm new to the
sport i don't know that much
but i think you're in the place now
where you have to where do you you want
to pay the man
you know and i think that you know
who was james j braddock where was he
from
oh he's an american boxer well i think
you got a new james j
braddock man that's what it felt like
the hot sauce boss baby that's
cinderella man himself
uh dustin the diamond poirier and um
and you know we love him here but i was
ecstatic man i was so so
you know i was i i was kind of bummed
for connor i mean you know i don't like
to see the people lose
i want i wish at the end every you know
everybody kind of won
but uh but yeah i watched it here in the
central east man and they all you know
michael channel lives here
and so they were going bankers for him
and his wife came back she went home and
watched it and then came back to the bar
after
and she was uh they were all cheering
when she came in it was pretty cool
um but yeah it was it was just a hopeful
time there was something hopeful about
it
there was something exciting about it
especially at a time when big business
is winning everything it feels like and
the little man has been knocked down
and then you see uh a man like dustin
who's not a little man but you see him
say hey not today not on my watch
um and i'm you know i'm done fanboying
but i was
you know i was just uh i was stoked for
him
the guy's been on quite a journey and he
and he has to prove himself every time
and i think a lot of us can relate to
that journey
of con of just constantly having to
prove ourselves
so man but it was definitely exciting
um what else
i'll tell you this and we'll get into
some calls you guys had some great calls
that came in um
places you enjoyed as a child eating
uh
you know um
different places like that and a couple
questions came in
um and then i want to talk about some
personal stuff as well
a little bit uh support for the podcast
this past weekend is brought to you by
manscaped
who is the best in men's below the belt
grooming
i can tell you right now it's manscaped
if you gonna put anything around your
your crotch or your nuts or your body or
your cooter it better be a manscaped
item
manscape just released their new cologne
sent to help you
feel and smell good all over and at all
times
buff your nuts out with that scent
look everyone knows manscape has the
perfect package 3.0 for all your below
the waist grooming needs
but now they got that refined cologne
signature sent
by manscape you don't want to be
smelling like somebody else's body
somebody else's ass or whatever
anything like that body low body
and manscape have a new refined cologne
signature scent
with the same signature scent that's in
all manscape formulas
a perfect complement to the manscape
collection
light approachable and gentlemanly
in all the right ways i think that
describes my crotch light and
approachable
uh be sure to check out um manscaped
refined cologne to complete your set and
smell great anytime
it's time to feel sexy they can help get
20
off from free shipping by going to
manscaped.com
t-h-e-o and support the podcast
um get 20 off from free shipping
by going to manscape.com theo that's 20
off with free shipping by going to
manscape.com
t-h-e-o look good smell good feel good
with
manscaped
um
what else
what else oh i don't know if you watched
ufc i don't know what was tougher
seeing michael chandler fight dan hooker
or then having to
watch michael chandler do a back flip
off of the cage
i don't know which one was harder for me
i don't know which
if i would rather have to fight dan
hooker
or do a backflip off the cage man
both looked extremely freaking insane
um but kudos to michael chandler man on
his victory and
probably the greatest ufc debut of all
time
to come right out and and a lot of time
in ufc they'll do
there's a bit of a dance in the
beginning
you know there's a bit of a non
kind of a non non-dancing capoeira of of
sorts of violent capoeira
but michael chandler didn't do that he
came straight out
like that dog like a you know
like a poor person neighborhood dog in
the in the in the 90s that thing
they ain't gonna smell you first man
it'll bite
so
ah and it's good so that's what was
going on
um what else
what else we got oh i want to recommend
a movie to you i watched
and this movie called our friend
on amazon and it's expensive it's a 20
it's a 20 buy-in
and you get to watch it you can watch it
three times if you want i watch it one
time
you know i'm no [ __ ] pervert but uh
and it's a sad when watch it with a
friend with a loved one
you know it's just uh
it's interesting but
um yeah
it's just an interesting move if you get
a chance you you watched everything you
haven't
watch our friend and uh
and i think you'll enjoy it uh what else
and another thing i watched was
tiger woods documentary
and i think it's on hbo maximum
and it's interesting
it's a lot about a father and son
in their relationship
and a lot about the media
you know um
[Music]
and a lot about popularity and fame and
you know the media really used tiger
you know his dad says in there he says
uh
you know this is my son this is my
greatest gift
use him wisely
and
at the end i feel like
jesus how is that it would email me
right now
my god sorry and by the end i feel like
you see like kind of how a father used
his son in some ways
you see how the media used
the father and the son
you see how the son used
things substances to make him feel okay
women sex you know anything you can be
addicted to sex
drugs gambling money
anger you know there's a food there's
every everything can be a
you know a supplement for addiction um
and it was just it was just this
fascinating circle of like
because his dad says use him wisely i
think is the line he says
no the father actually he says this is
my treasure
please accept it and use it wisely
and yeah it's just fascinating just how
much like work
the dad put i think he saw this a
natural gift in his son for um
doing golf golf you know golf golf
and then um
and then just took it to another level
you know spent so much time and
and training him
and then kind of you know i think
probably from the father's eyes it
looked like kind of unleashed him on the
world
um
and it's just fat it's just pretty
fascinating like because then the media
played like this race card
but i'm sure tiger and his family they
were all in it you know they were it was
just
you know it's just the way media does
things um try to get an
angle you know
but then he gets so big and so popular
that just the pressure of like
finding something that's just his own
you know you'll find addiction that's
easy
um and it talks about his addiction to
women
sex addiction um
[Music]
which some of the stuff i can relate to
and i could just relate to nothing like
on his level of popularity i don't mean
that but just
you know the feeling of something inside
of you
not being there and needing something on
the outside
to make you forget that
you're missing whatever you're missing
um but it's fascinating man those are
two good things to watch if you like to
watch stuff
if you like to look at stuff now if you
just want to go back to high school and
buy
drugs you can holler at your boy big pet
all right
slick you can holler at spoony spotty
otty ricky
you know la danny brother
so did i remember being at school
and the drug dogs came in there
and i was high as hell man i was high as
[ __ ] four gay dudes in a [ __ ] hot
air balloon brother [ __ ] high as [ __ ]
you know i was [ __ ] ah
you know what i'm saying if you need me
i'll be up there [ __ ] i'm a
and um i remember just i was scared of
dogs at the time
and i'm like hiding by the teacher and
[ __ ] and they thought i was all [ __ ]
up
and i was i was high but i was also
scared of dogs you know which really
kind of feel like the same thing
and uh and i asked the teacher point
blank i said well can the dog just smell
if i'm high
and he asked the policeman that was with
the dog and they said no
i said all right we good then fine we
good let's get to some of your calls but
first i got to let you know that uh
the time is coming to get your body
right
and god i need it man
man i've been in just so much pain man i
just got so much pain from
just man every every freaking week
something's wrong with my body bro
and i'm sorry to sound like i'm
complaining but i want to go do jiu
jitsu i want to be able to do yoga i
want to be able to do the things i want
to do
and i've just been feeling beaten down
you know it's a new year and it's
and it is it is my resolution as it is
many people's
to get in better shape
physically and mentally and i like to
work out
but sometimes the workouts you want to
do you can't do them
it says you need a uh you know you need
a couple barbells you need a hillside
and a big boulder like just
some of the workouts is too egregious
or agri edges bruh and i don't want to
spend 2 000
on a tony little gazelle freestyler or
some susan sarandon you know
you know a damn uh you know a swimming
tank or something for your yard i can't
afford it
so i'm saying beachbody on demand offers
1500 at home workouts plus nutrition
plans
so no matter what your goals are they
have a program that will help you build
and keep healthy habits come on come on
this is the company behind p90x insanity
and 21 day fix
anytime you've ever seen a black guy or
asian guy getting fit on television
they're behind that check out
beachbody's newest programs like muscle
burns fat
and 80 day obsession
they have celebrity super trainers like
tony horton joelle freeman
and autumn calabrese calabrese
you can access it anywhere anytime 2020
is
behind us it's a new year and it's time
to get in shape
to get a special free trial no
obligation membership text
t-h-e-o to 30-30-30
that's right text th eo to 30 30 30
you'll get full access to the entire
platform
all the workouts nutrition information
and support
you need support absolutely free it's
free
just text t-a-g-e-o to 30 30
30. oh thank you guys for your patience
man
oh
they have a slipped disc like in the top
of my back and man it is
it's a lot sorry to bring that on this
show but it is a lot at the moment
let's get into some calls you guys had
some great calls
and people saying what they done and
things like that
and i want to hear it you know first we
had that last week um
want to say hit the hotline man hit that
h baby
hit the hot line i think i'm losing my
voice
um for
uh if you went to a special place to eat
you know when i was young we went to
[ __ ] pizza bj's pizza they called it
and they said it stood for bg uh black
jacks
but everybody knew the truth baby people
was blowing each other sucking off
you know touching dick to mouth mouth to
dick baby you know what i'm saying
praise god bro
so um here we go couple calls came in
let's hear it
what's up theo this is your boy brian
coming at you from
st petersburg florida oh brian
and saint petersburg dude it's a good
place to get a
final buried treasure maybe see a damn
tattooed tit bro
[ __ ] yeah my own homework
and i was just listening to your round
italians episode
and you were talking about going to bj's
pizza
when you were a kid with your family and
you you asked us
if we had any memories growing up always
going to an eatery
i grew up in the suburbs of chicago and
we'd go to this pizza place called papa
pisceros
oh papa paceros huh let's hear more
about this
about this beautiful spot
and you would think because chicago is
good pizza but but very similar to your
bj's
incident uh the pizza sucked man but i
know they had cheap beer so
my parents and my aunts and uncles would
go out on a friday night we'd all get
beer and pizza and they had a big old
arcade
and they'd send us into the arcade which
was some quarters be playing mortal
kombat and all the games
and the one memory i had to stuff out of
this one boy i don't know his name
but he would always dominate the mortal
kombat machine
and he would keep his quarters in his
mouth it was the strangest thing and
he'd get done beating somebody
flawless victory with scorpio and he'd
spit out like a little lizard spit out a
couple quarters
throw them back in the machine say who's
next damn man and that's a sign usually
of uh
eating disorder you know that could be
some type of eating disorder maybe um
but yeah every arcade had some kid at it
that you didn't know from your town
you're like who
there's only 40 kids in town i knows
them all
and who is this magic man some little
fella named laser or some
every arcade had some weird-ass kid that
you've never seen before
who was always winning all the games and
doing this and that
dude i was always the weirdo at arcade
where i would like i'd have to check
every little thing
then i'd go outside and check the
newspaper machine see if they had a
quarter
and then um sometimes the video game
somebody would have dropped a quarter
and it would have got stuck
under so i'd look under there sometime i
get a piece of paper and fold it over
about four times make me a paper stick
make me a stick but out of paper it's
almost like
because a paper was a stick so really
you just doing some damn
it's almost like when you see a
mannequin made out of actual human body
parts you're like damn okay this is
you know this is back back fourth and
fourth you know what i'm saying this is
refurbishment
but um but i'd make a paper stick and i
would try to slot
reach under the machine and see if
there's because there's only about an
eighth of an inch there
and it was dust in there it's nasty
they usually have a little runt or a
little gumball down there
and i would slide that paper trying to
knock a quarter out the end
um or look behind the machine there was
a button behind the machine sometimes
you could press it it would turn the
machine on and off and i would always
like wait for it to come on and think it
was going to let me have a free game and
it wouldn't
and then there was always the person
that would sit there and watch you play
all the games that dude
that kid whoever that kid was a little
benji or a little tragic
we had a little black kid busting him
tragic right
and man he was he never had a damn dime
right he sit there and watch you play
he why he wouldn't say nothing bro
damn he wouldn't say no i don't know if
he ever even said nothing
he might still be just looking at
something
but um
what else what'd you say man yeah it was
fun though the video games was a big
part
and i would get what was that game super
ice brothers let me see
super ice super
ice bros no that wasn't it
yeah super maybe it was smash brothers
but it was an old one
i thought it was ice bros
yeah there was some gain just i don't
even know some of the games were just so
old oh castlevania
and you get to you know it's like i
don't know what it was it was like some
guy that was like kind of like
it was like zillow for vampires it was
like some guy that was looking for
a castle i guess i don't remember he
you know he just couldn't really find
i don't remember what it was it was like
fi i don't remember if the place had a
draw
he didn't lie what he was fighting but
you were
he had a whip and you were angry at the
realtors and you were like looking for a
nice castle but you couldn't find what
you wanted
um you know you'd be in like a 60
bedroom castle and you'd be pissed off
them yeah
just i don't know i wasn't real good at
it but mom or dad give you that quarter
and you go ah when you put that quarter
in just the feeling you had
i got a chance all right hit the buttons
a couple times before the game starts
move the joystick
man it was fun that was a good time
thank you for the call as always the
hotline 985-664-9503 let's hear another
one
hi sam vaughn it's molly martin from new
albany indiana
molly martin from new albany
indiana and indiana is a good place to
really pull over on the side of the road
and think about
you know think about uh some of the
choices you've made
onward baby let's hear more and i'm
calling because i just listened to your
episode today with chris
the first person with down syndrome to
complete the iron man
and i was crying from the first minute
to
like i'm crying the whole whole episode
it was so heartwarming especially
because my older brother has down
syndrome and
okay so you got that insider trading
baby you really
that really would hit that would hit uh
close to home
if you have that onward thank you for
listening it just meant a lot to me
to see the way that you gave him uh
the space to express himself and you did
such a good job of like
asking him questions and and having
conversation with him
i was really impressed and touched by
that and chris is so inspirational he's
inspiring me to make my own dream board
and to stop making excuses for myself of
why
i can't do this or that and um and to be
focused every day on my dreams
and um i also really hope that you guys
do that double date
um that you talked about on the podcast
oh yeah i think we'll we might try that
i'm gonna aim for it
you know i mentioned terrace terence
ross on the podcast and
uh and he plays for orlando's magic
and if if i can when the world's open
i'll go to a game and
see if we can't find a couple nickels
man
i mean we'll take dimes but we'll settle
for nickels baby you feel me
uh but that'd be fun if me and chris are
going to double date to the game so i
would love to do it
so i'm going to see if i can't make that
happen um
and then you know obviously terrence
will have to get us tickets but that's
on terrence
you know that is on terence man that
ain't my problem terrence
uh so we'll see what happens man but no
molly i
appreciate you uh checking it out you
know
man i just went through such a week of
like uplifting moments there was um
there was the chris interview there was
the dustin win
uh tom brady making it back to this just
things that made you feel
hopeful i think things that made you
feel
like uh
like like everything is like there's me
there is magic happening
and i needed that
you know and it was one of the most
interesting things about being around
chris was
well first just from looking at him
there's a they're because they're
they're
their heads this assumption that
that there's some that he like he can't
hear you sometimes or that he's not
paying attention like um i don't know
what it is you know and it's not from
him it's just from
being having been around other ds
children and stuff like that and ds
you know um
and you know were you you kind of
i don't know i think i i went into it
with this curiosity like what is it
really
like to be inside of him to
you know and not i'm not talking
sexually or not like that i'm talking uh
from a point of like what is it like for
his frame of reference for the world
you know and how can i get that how can
i see what he's seeing
because i had a time one time i was in a
halloween costume and it was in there
and it was sweaty and
i could look out the eye slots but
the the mask was real thick and
and i couldn't move that grade and it
was hard people couldn't hear me
and i felt like man i wonder if this is
what it's like to have like a down
syndrome or autism
you know like you can see the world but
it just can't
you can't interact with it the way you
want to
because that's what i had felt i'd felt
trapped a little
um
so i think i wish i would have asked
chris more things like uh what are
things that he likes to smell
you know like um i wish i would talk to
him more about feelings
and asked his dad if he has like all the
same feelings that
uh people without down syndrome have you
know non-de-essers
um
but hey i think there could be another
opportunity i was extremely just
inspired by
and also it was cool to see he's 22. or
he
man i mean he 22 or 21 who gives at that
age who cares
you know he's so he's thinking about
women just like i was at that age
just like i still am half the time
so it's just dope to see that look he's
still he's feeling he's trying to find
this other element
that may be out there for him that lady
you know smoking hot
i love that man he's gonna be smoking
hot
smoking hot man but it was special and
his dad was special and uh
you know i just felt lucky to be in
their presence that's kind of what i
felt like
so yeah god bless him man
you know and
and yeah we can do it whatever it is
you know what is it what did he say the
pain
or your dreams
the pain or your dreams you know
and he just kept choosing his dreams but
thank you for that call
molly and be safe out there i saw an owl
get
uh denigrated one time or i don't know
if that's a word but
killed by a tow truck over there
on 52 or 53 heading from indianapolis to
uh bloomington
so all right uh
let's take another call that came in
right here man um
here we go hey theo this is will
i wanted to call in um let you know
about what restaurants i used to hit
when i was a kid
it reminded me of when you were talking
about my mom taking me to uh hardee's
when she would be taking us to school in
the morning you know it was uh
we'd always get a little uh just a
biscuit you know you get a biscuit real
cheap and then we'd get a little uh
the jelly packets for free so we could
have a biscuit with jelly
oh yeah baby that free jelly
god whoever invented free jelly baby
praise god
i mean they knew they knew they knew i
was gonna come into the world
and i would be looking for something
like that you know something when i
think about somehow
some of them i'll lay in bed at night
and just think about all the packets of
free jelly that are out there
behind every counter at every you know
fast food joint just right under the
just right under the ledge
just a bucket of damn free jellies baby
and dual jellies
strawberry and grape strawberry and red
baby
and sometime i just can't even sleep
just thinking about all the individual
packets
and you know first jelly was all
together and then they [ __ ] separated
it man
and i don't know who came in the germans
or a bunch of business people came in
and just
you know hey hey no no no
no no no this video's on
you know and then they put it all in a
little packet little orphan
little orphan tees tablespoons of jelly
bruh
and i call it yelly sometimes
but damn there's something beautiful man
if you close your eyes and think about
all the jelly that's out there
god this
i mean it's remarkable
he's remarkable brother and yeah i feel
you man i remember when
when we had a little bit of money when
mom had sold something you know mom
sometime would sell different items
you know when she did newspapers and she
would do sometime uh
you know cookies this company called
vortman cookies
and i'd sneak out to her car at night
and have me about 30 30 damn oatmeal
cookies or something you know 45
shortbreads or all kind of [ __ ]
so full of cookie i couldn't even get
back to the house man
so full i couldn't even bend my body i
was walking like a gingerbread man
which was ironic because i just had nine
of them
and uh but son of mom would take us to
get a
bacon egg and cheese biscuit from
mcdaniels baby
god i mean
that was my roof's crips daddy
and i remember the wrapper at the time
it said bacon egg and cheese biscuit
own it so if a girl walked by i'd
[ __ ]
i would wait till a girl walked by and
that's when i would open it so she would
see the side
[ __ ] i got all these ingredients up in
yeah
you know this that full monty baby
this that buffet grenade baby this bacon
egg and yes
and there was something special about it
man there was something about it
and i missed that man that was fun and
someone my father would go with us too
when i was real young
he only went once or twice before we got
they got divorced but he
he he would go sometimes
but i remember that man it was nice man
i felt man i felt fancy
i really really felt fancy when we got
that um
let's take another call here we go
yo what up theo it's me and elliot down
from here in georgia
what's up elliot down there in georgia
brother you know
not the country in europe but you know
the state
oh yeah georgia's a good place to get a
a
hickey from somebody who you know
who uh
really for anybody some some people
they give it to you as a form of payment
you know they paint
they paint you know you paint their
fence and they come out suck on your
neck for 30 seconds
bruh it's just that kind of town baby
let's go again god's good baby but
what i'm wondering is rumors were
spreading around my old high school
that i'm a homosexual you know kids
thinking i'm a i'm gay really
and oh yeah gay man gay adult yes sir
onward
it's pretty stressful okay because you
know i don't want people to think that
and be nothing wrong with that but you
know i'm just not
personally into men like that i like
women
you know but you know they're over here
saying i like men
and that's a lot on my plate so i just
need some advice for that
take it easy have a wonderful day gang
brother and look i feel for you man i
know it's uh
you know i don't think that you know
people don't like rumors
and rumor is just a fairy tale that's
fired specifically at you like a gun
like one person pulls out a damn fairy
tale gun and just you know caps your ass
that's rumor and
and if they saying use uh in the
homosexuality then that's
that's could be alarming because if
you're in a small area
and you there's only about nine women to
date if five of them here to rumors you
down to four women
you know and if one of them doesn't like
athletic activities and you like to jog
in the morning then you down to three
women
so yeah it's tough when rumors like that
happen
but some of it you just gotta man up and
just you know i maybe it's maybe it's a
sign that you need to start taking
dating seriously
it could be another man in town planted
the rumor
because they're trying to get the real
dimes and you over here penny pension
you know what i'm saying
so you're going to be stuck
you're going to be stuck with a woman
that's less than a nickel dog unless you
get out there and hunt
because if he says that and then the
local ladies say oh well look
you know the little elliot out there
slurping that bone
then i you know i can't offer it
i have nothing to offer him because i
got titty
but um what i would say
is man uh well first of all there's
always when i was young
it they had a rumor if you had on a uh
turtleneck you was get you were gay or
flirting for gay
you know basically bait fishing for gay
he was letting other gay men or you know
kind of homeowners or whatever
know that you were available
and i didn't know that [ __ ] man and i
remember a turtleneck truck
uh broke down near our house and
somebody robbed it or whatever and next
thing you know everybody in our
neighborhood had turtlenecks
blue and green
and we wearing them [ __ ] man people
was cutting the sleeves off them
cutting the turtle off i'm cutting the
neck off from people grilling them some
people thought it was made out of real
turtle made soup out of them
you know it was different time but
suddenly a lot of men
you know what i'm saying man
[Music]
showed up in our neighborhood because
they saw the turtlenecks
and they come over and kind of you know
ask you how you was doing to try and
give you a little butterscotch or
something
so it's risky man it's a you know but
there's always stuff that's going to
happen and it's how you react to it
brother
and i don't think this is that big of an
issue but
you know i think maybe it's just a sign
that it's time for you to get out there
and start being real with these ladies
and quit pea footing around you know
what i'm saying
let's hear another call that came in man
and thank you guys i want to say thank
you for supporting this podcast
and for being a part of my life um
you know i feel so so grateful we have a
lot of uh
man i just feel grateful
i feel grateful i'm just glad that i
started podcasting
you know i didn't know that i was going
to do podcasting
and then i started so
let's take one or two more calls here
man let's see what we got right here
uh onward what up theo
this is kellen from michigan what's up
kellen and uh michigan
is a good place to [ __ ] somebody with uh
mittens on
let's hear more um last week you were
talking about
special restaurants or places you would
go and you brought up tim hortons so i
thought i'd
use tim hortons when i was a kid i would
go camping in canada
and oh that's a good good way to go
missing onward i'd get tim hortons you
know their bagels
good coffee and [ __ ] i guess i didn't
get the coffee i was a kid
then bagels baby them jewish rounds baby
onward
but i always thought tim hortons was
just in canada and then we went
downstate
to the cities now i was like oh tim
hortons is everywhere
anyways i always thought that was cool
and when i go there today i think about
camping with my parents and stuff so
gang gang gang gang brother that's an
anticlimactic story
but you know i will say there's
something f there's something unique
when you find out that
whatever is yours locally is everywhere
i remember that
i remember thinking wait wait wait
mcdonald they have a mcdonald's
you know josh has a mcdonald's in his in
in his town
you know they have a mcdonald's across
the bridge they have two mcdonald's
yeah i thought mcdonald's was just mine
just ours when he was young
and that orange soda god it was good
damn my god it was good
um but thank you for calling brother
appreciate that
all right let's take one more call that
came in here man onward
i see you my name's john i'm from
upstate new york i'm 17 years old
i'm a senior in high school and i'm
going off to uh
well i'm going off to the world after
this and i
thank you for calling john i appreciate
your brother and i appreciate you
uh and uh upstate new york
and they cut somebody's head off one
time up there on a greyhound bus man i'm
sorry for reminding everybody about that
and i didn't plan on reminding you but
i just said it and then i realized you
know that i'd said it
um i can't believe you're 17 jeepers man
you're in high school about to graduate
from what
sounding like an adult technical
institution broadca do you sound like
bro hold on a second let's go back and
hear you dog
and i love you brother i do want to tell
you that homework i see you my name's
john i'm from
upstate new york i'm 17 years old hi
theo my name is john
i think my name is john i'm revolts
dude you sound 52 years old brother
uh and you're going out to see the world
what are you in a charles dickens novel
let's hear more
old i'm a senior in high school and i'm
going off to uh
well i'm going off to the world after
this and i the world are you lenny from
of mice and men
is this brendan is this
brennan shaw who owes me that thousand
onward
i i'm just not quite sure what i want to
do with my life
you know i i work hard i i don't get the
best grades in school but i work hard
and i just want to hear your thoughts on
this what do you think a young man
should do
thank you very much gang brother gang
brother and i'm sorry i was making funny
man but also i was just having a good
time
what would i do if i was 17 right now
with a deep voice
i'd probably do some [ __ ] honestly if
i'm real honest with you man i'd do
mating i'd mate with women with that
voice man you could
you could probably make love to half
your mother's friends but um
what would i do if i were 17.
you know if you weren't really sure what
you would wanted to do i i don't think
joining the military would be a bad idea
because you're going to get a lot of
direction you're going to get
physically in shape you're going to get
camaraderie
and i don't think we're going to
hand-to-hand combat anymore
we've kind of evolved out of a lot of
that
you know a lot of war now is more press
of a button
more pomp and circumstance
you know more kind of like the
introductions but not the actual start
of the round
um
so i and here's the thing you'd be done
by 21 and you're the rest of your life
you would
you would be so regimented i think and
have such a good structure
that from then on you would be able to
achieve anything you wanted
if i could go back in time i'd have more
structure
that's what i would have
um so
what else um
i don't know man maybe race carrying
you know start with like a real beater
or something start with maybe a toyota
tercel
or something yeah
or something like that get out there
dodge neon
soup that bad job don't watch neon
um i'm upstairs
uh yeah i would do something like that
maybe
i don't know man what is it you know
i would learn digital some type of a
digital skill
or i'd learn how to teach people to hunt
with birds you know i would just find
something that you kind of like and if
you don't know what you like then try
things until you find something you do
you know one time i remember i went up
to the counter at this
recreational facility
and there was a cute girl working there
and i was trying to holler at her and
this is
about nine years ago and
and i was kind of bored in my life i was
just bored
and she said well if you're bored you're
boring that's what she said
and i'm not saying that you're bored
brother i'm not saying that your brother
i'm not saying you're bored john from
new york that's 50 or 40.
um
but there's a lot of things out there
man
and we just got to go do them and try
them out
so i'd say just make a little list of
things
that you love or things even that you're
afraid of
and like brooks was said like brooks
said man get busy living
you know i don't know if he said it or
not he died he died at the grocery store
and he killed himself
but um
what else man i think that's about it
brother uh
that's it man i want to thank you guys
we didn't do intro music on this one
you know sometimes we have trouble
getting some of the music cleared
uh but next week we'll get back to some
music
so it's kind of interesting having
having no music
you know keeps the egg right on the
grill i feel like
it doesn't give me as much to hide
behind
so
but we'll talk i got some personal stuff
i want to bring up next time and we'll
get into some of it or whatever nothing
real crazy but
just want to you know share just some
things that's going on and
and um and just to say thank you man
thank you for being a part of my life
and a part of this interesting journey
that i've gotten to go on
with podcasting and talking to unique
people that are having
unique lives and and i don't get to talk
to them if you're not here with me
um because all i'm doing is just
listening really
same as you so you guys be good to
yourselves man
and uh and i love you
and i mean that i even lived i even love
john's old ass little 40 50 year old ass
bro
hi hi huh hi theo i'm five
six years old hi theo i'm four
yeah i've been working at the factory i
don't
yeah i can't even i can't even buy a can
of dip in my crib
oh man ah
you guys be good to yourselves man how
about that diamond baby
pretty cool pretty cool to watch a lot
of neat stuff happening in the world man
and it can happen to other people and it
can happen to us man you got to be good
to yourselves man
let's go bishop gun baby making it
i ain't seen home in about a hundred
days i can almost hear
mama pray for my restless soul
[Music]
and i ain't made a dollar i ain't spent
[Music]
i'm tired man let's go baby i'm making
it come on
[Music]
i'm making good time
[Music]
and um all of my plants slip
right through my hands and wind up next
to me
broken on the ground
if this bottle was an hourglass i'd say
that i'm about an
hour past the minute i should have put
it down
[Music]
but i'm making it i make it wrong
i feel right
[Music]
i'm making it and it helps when i'm
heading there
i'm making good time
oh
and
[Music]
but i'm in pretty good shape
for
[Music]
i'm in pretty good shape for the shape
that i'm in that's the truth
you guys be good to yourselves man you
deserve it and uh and uh i'll see you
next week